so what does all this mean for americans
when it comes to our bottom line in
today's eight on your side kirsten joyce
breaks down the immediate impact on our
wallets likely to last for the next
several months
[Music]
the most severe impact to americans
coming out of the crisis in ukraine will
be an increase in gas prices the price
of oil has already been going up we've
seen oil and gas prices up by 40 percent
from a year ago we're headed higher
unfortunately the latest from aaa shows
we're paying 3.54 cents nationally for a
gallon of gas if this crisis continues
cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger says we can see oil gas
prices utility prices up even more add
to that a hike in agricultural prices
for wheat and corn because russia and
the ukraine are big exporters and we
could see metal prices when we look at
iron ore we look at palladium used in
those chips that we need in cars so all
this is going to add to inflationary
pressures at least in the short term
with inflation at a 40-year high
economist expected the seven and a half
percent to drift a little higher but now
with the crisis in ukraine i'm talking
to economists who say this could go up
to nine percent inflation so everything
is going to cost more with a conflict
that could cost a lot of economic damage
markets are going to be volatile her
advice to investors take a deep breath
don't panic if they go down big today
they could go up big tomorrow try not to
react stick to that game plan remember
if you're a long-term investor these
moments are real tests kirstjen joyce
live local now